[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar ngs library prep and
quantification on the ot2 today's
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by opentrons to learn
more visit opentrons.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble hearing
or seeing the presentation
i'm canary watson a director at
opentrons and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's speaker will be matt akana lead
ngs scientist at opentrons he'll be
presenting data he has produced on
automating ngs library prep on the ot2
as well as quantification normalization
and pooling of ngs libraries
before we start the presentation i want
to introduce you to the ot2 the ot2 is a
liquid handling robot that's different
from other liquid handlers it was
designed to be accessible to any life
scientist
it's highly accurate but extremely
affordable and small enough to fit on
half a lab bench
it's flexible and open so you can add
different pipettes and modules depending
on the application and you can use your
existing reagents and labware
it's accessible to users with and
without automation experience with a
user-friendly gui protocol designer and
an advanced python api
we offer support from free onboarding to
custom protocol development and
technical support
and you can automate a wide range
of applications on this platform some of
the most common applications are ngs
library prep and quantification pcr
setup nucleic acid isolation and
purification small scale protein
purification biochemical assays as well
as general liquid handling procedures
including cereal dilution and cherry
picking microplate and tube filling as
well as normalization and sample
preparation
matthew you may now begin your
presentation
all right thank you for that
introduction and let's get started so
first i'm going to go over an agenda of
some of the things i'll be talking about
in this presentation so first of all is
the basics of ngs workflow that is next
generation sequencing in particular um
what i'm talking about is sequencing on
an illumina
based sequencer
and then going into some more in-depth
about a library prep on the ot2 what it
is we've done so far and how do we
approach doing that
using nlt2
and then taking time to talk about
quantification normalization and pooling
these are steps that are crucial to ngs
but are not really elaborated
too much on in the protocols for your
library prep a lot of this stuff is are
left for the user to figure out on their
own and a lot of these solutions are
particular to each individual lab so how
do we tackle some of these things using
the ot2
basics of the ngs workflow
this is a workflow and you'll be seeing
it again as i refer to it in my
presentation these are sort of the steps
how you go from like a sample type all
the way to sequencing so we're breaking
it down on the left is the extraction
extracting your sample
then goes through a few qc steps the
pico green to quantify it and
normalizing it to get this all ready for
the actual library prep here this slide
is all condensed into just one step for
library prep but this will get uh we
will go into this in some of the next
slides
following that you have your prepared
samples so you go through more quality
control checks make sure it's ready and
able to be sequenced
finally qpcr in order to get a real
accurate
quantification of your sample pulling
them all together and then putting it on
the sequencer
so
uh some of my approach to doing this on
the ot2 is each of these little blocks
would be a separate protocol and they're
all run on the same robot
some of my approaches here for tackling
the various library prep kits was to do
bad sizes of about 24 samples i found
that's a good number that's not too big
or too small as just about the right
workload for the robot setup that i have
you can do more samples going up to
maybe 48 samples
but beyond that you begin to get
diminishing returns as we get into the
robot you'll see that we have
a pair of multi multi eight channel pipe
pets so as it goes the samples that
we'll do is one column at a time and as
each column is treated separately during
a step such as ampere cleanup uh the
more columns you have the slower it
takes so above 48 samples you're going
to get sort of diminishing returns on
the amount of time saved also the deck
space is a bit limited so if you do go
beyond 24 samples you will have to be in
close proximity to sort of reset some of
the tip boxes
so why automate on the ot2 um some
perspectives is
uh
96 samples is a
minimum amount that needs to be
automated because everything could be
treated as a single block there's larger
robots for that but
for
my purposes i previously worked in a
clinical lab in which we did small
samples batches but we did them
repeatedly because sample turnaround
time was quite important so we want
to be able to do small batches
repeatedly and be flexible enough to
change between 16 samples 8 samples or
24 samples
so this is a deeper look into the actual
library prep
basically what library prep is is taking
your dna molecules and they're breaking
them down into manageable chunks that
could be read on the sequencer
i think the aluminum-based sequencers
can read maybe 150 to 300 cycles what
that means is it could do 150 to 300
bases being read if you get molecules
longer than that full sequence but you
might be missing some of
the sequence in the middle of the
molecule and anything even longer might
not even cluster
accurately on the flow cell
so it's breaking up the dna into
manageable chunks that's through a
fragmentation fragmentation uh depending
on what technique you use usually it
leaves a random overhang it just breaks
the molecule randomly throughout the uh
the entire length
this followed up by end repair which
blunts it it trims off the overhang and
usually a tailing which adds a a base so
it leaves a region that can
the adapter could be ligated onto
as you see in the ligation we're adding
on an adapter usually this one contains
a unique barcode so later you're able to
combine these samples together and run
them on the sequencer in one batch this
is well you can multiplex multiple
samples together
as you go and look at different library
protocols
some protocols had different techniques
in which they split up the adapter into
two parts sometimes there's a full
length adapter including
the bar code as well as the regions
needed for sequencing and binding to the
flow cell other times they can split up
the adapter so actually the barcode
comes in later during the amplification
step
as you get deeper into
ngs library prep depending on what your
project is
a lot of things can be switched around
or replaced or changed maybe you're
working with amplicons so you don't need
the fragmentation at the beginning
you're already designing regions to
amplify that are already in the exact
size you want
sometimes you want to
actually avoid or you don't need the
amplification either you start with a
surplus of your sample dna so you don't
need to amplify it or maybe even you
want to avoid the amplification bias or
any bias that's introduced so you would
skip the pcr amplification and final
cleanup
throughout all of this quantification is
important
this is a slide that i'll be referring
to again later generally showing on the
left side
of the forms of quantification for a
high concentration sample
and on the right side something for low
concentration throughout the course of
your protocol your samples will get
smaller in volume lowering concentration
and then you will want to pick out at
the end just specific molecules just the
ones that will sequence the ones with
the p5 p7
so
for all these different stages there's a
best fit form of quantification at the
beginning you could do something like
spectrophotometry just looking at the
absorbance let's say you're extracting
samples out of saliva or
blood or something messy
you have your extracted sample you want
to check the purity so 260 280 is pretty
good
this method is pretty cheap and fast you
don't need anything
any additional reagent kit as long as
you have a spectrophotometer
but this is only good to get a ballpark
sense of what your dna is
the the numbers in blue i
would serve sort of as a guideline
between a cut off between if you want to
do spectra or fluorescence
in the mid-range which will probably be
the bulk of your quantification methods
is fluorescence
this is generally like a pico green kit
so it uses a intercalating dye so it's a
dye that fits between the grooves of the
double-stranded nucleic acid be it dna
or some other weird form of rna
so this quantifies based on mass
so it's much more specific than doing it
with spectrophotometry because now is
ignoring anything that was also
absorbing or
obscuring the results so now it's only
the double-stranded nucleic material
this is a longer process it is more
reliable it is more specific but it does
require a reagent kit as well as a
fluorometer that can read it
and then finally is once you have your
final prepared libraries diluted down
you want to do qpcr so this is
quantification based on a specific
primer amplification the p5 p7 and this
qualifies based on quantity not mass
this
becomes kind of important if you have
fragment sizes that either
that maybe something went wrong in your
protocol your fragments are way too long
or way too short
fluorescence if you have a bunch of
short molecules or fewer long molecules
since it's based on mass you wouldn't be
able to tell apart so qpcr is based on
just the quantity of molecules that will
actually amplify actually bind and
amplify on the flow cell
pcr pretty accurate but it is expensive
it is time consuming it is very specific
and it is very sensitive so this is what
is used at the very end to qualify your
libraries before putting it on the
sequencer
now let's look at it on an ot2
here we started with three kits
alumina dna prep
roche hyper prep and neb ultra two
for these three kits we did the same
starting material of 100 nanograms of
lambda dna and eight replicates one
entire column
there is an important difference between
these two types of kits
for alumina
the dna prep is a tagmentation
so this is different from the library
prep i mentioned earlier which use
fragmentation tagmentation uses
illumina's transpose to both
fragment and tag the adapter
simultaneously so that's why they call
it fragmentation
they've gone the extra mile to make it
extra fancy by making it bead linked so
the transpose ace is linked to a bead so
not only does it
fragment and tag it simultaneously it
will wash away anything that hasn't been
tagged fragmented
on the other side is hyper prep and the
neb next ultra 2.
these are similar to each other
this outside the
steps of the protocol they leave the
fragmentation up to the user
so here in our particular case we use
the enzymatic fragmentation but it's
open-ended enough in this side so that
you can use other forms of fragmentation
such as sonication or nebulization
those two methods are low cost but
they're also very low throughput they
don't require
additional reagents maybe an instrument
but you'll be sitting there sonicating
one sample at a time
our approach was using the more
automation friendly enzymatic method
using an enzyme to do the fragmentation
this does require an additional ampere
cleanup to get it ready for the library
prep but this was this was done up front
both of these were done with four cycles
of pcr amplification
this is what the ot2 deck looked like
throughout all my protocols my approach
is to have as many modules on the deck
as possible so that there's no need to
stop and switch decks
modules or pipettes
so
[Music]
you can't see it here but this is using
a p20 multi and a p300 multi
on the top left you have a thermocycler
it is pretty bulky it's on deck
thermocycler from opentrons but does
take up positions 8 and 11 as you can
see
down in the bottom left is the magnet
module down the bottom right is the
temperature module
my approach was to have all the reagents
were pre-aliquoted onto a 96-well plate
and kept it four degrees throughout the
course of the protocol
as you know for the ngs protocol i'm
going to be adapting on barcodes each
one is unique usually they come in 96 or
even 384 well plates
and to avoid needing to stop the
protocol and hunt pick i replated the
barcodes just the ones i was using into
this 96
well reagent plate so that when the
barcodes are added i just use a
multi-channel i don't need to hunt and
hunt and pick during my protocol
so everything is prepared and ready to
go
here's what some of these components
look like
here's the ot2 the p300 and p20
multi-channel pipettes the magnetic
module it has a motor function so it can
engage and disengage so the magnet goes
up and down if you want to disengage the
magnet
temperature module which heats and cools
and the thermocycler module that goes on
the deck
for all the qualifications i was
mentioning here's the additional
instruments and kits that were being
used
so these forms of qualifications are
particular to each lab in particular to
the scale with the number the size of
the batches you'll be running sometimes
you want a small little fluorometer
sometimes you need something larger like
a plate reader
and going quickly here uh here are
slides of some of the data from those
three different ngs kits we did
again this is a hundred nanograms of
lambda dna on the left we have
batches of just eight samples so it
would be one row of
one row of a plate going through the
protocol
on the right is when we're doing sets of
batches of 24 which would be three rows
so if i was doing
as i mentioned the diminishing returns
if i was doing 48 samples that would be
like three columns one to get that would
be like excuse me six columns if i were
to do the amp purification i would have
to wait so
adding more samples for
draws out the protocol
what i'm looking what you want to look
at here is the cv at the bottom the
coefficient of variation which is the
standard dev divided by the average this
is a shorthand way to sort of measure
precision
what i wanted to see here is values
below 20 percent
here it is for the hyper prep
and here it is for anybody next ultra
again all the cv values are below 20.
here are some
traces from a fragment analyzer fragment
analyzer is like a gel electrophoresis
that sort of measures
uh it sort of separates the molecules
based on size so the bottom axis is
time or size the top axis
top axis is a fluorescence intensity so
what i wanted to see here is for uniform
smears
for all the samples
if you remember the segmentation and the
fragmentation are random so it's not
it's just cutting this the dna molecules
randomly over time so hopefully you get
a smear within the right
size what i'm looking for here based on
what my sequencer was going to be was
about 250 to 300 base pair libraries
using a fragment analyzer is a good way
to check for if you have any
adapter dimers or to see if there's any
additional
humps
that are of larger molecules
and should there be anything
weird you can do ampere science
selection to sort of tighten up the size
of the smear
here's a table of the variety of sample
types and batch sizes that we've done
between eight to 24 we've done lambda
human genomic dna
uh the cvs for all of them as you can
see are below 20
and the frame and sizes are between the
250 to like 300 that i was looking for
here's some
pie charts just showing the sample read
representation when i sequenced these
libraries of eight samples each
so we took each one we sequenced it and
we wanted to see roughly the
representation of each sample it should
be like 1 8 of a pie slice
this is with normalizing by hand
this is a summary of some of the run
metrics of how the robot
performed each run
so for each of them breaking it down
between 24 samples 16 samples or 8
samples how many tips were required and
how much time
p20s usually one box the p 300s multiple
boxes and then the column on the right
side is when i used
tip reusing
so this take this tip we're using is
sort of a ease of use feature that uh a
user can sort of program into the script
to reuse tips to take advantage of the
bot being able to keep track of these
tips and their positions versus you
can't do it by hand but as an additional
headache
this is particularly reusing tips only
for the ethanol washes or in the case of
illumina for the
the tag mutation bead washes
i would switch out a deep well and use a
as a sweet shot a reservoir and use a
deep well with individual wells for each
tip so they would keep clean and there
would be let there be no
cross-contamination
it's a ease of use feature it reduces
the amount of trash the amount of
tips used
and it reused for me it reduces the the
need for my intervention to reset tips
if you see with the
reusing tip boxes at most i use only
three boxes of the p 300
for my deck setup i can only fit
three boxes of the 300 so we'd use one
whole deck setup i wouldn't have to
pause and reset things
i still these protocols are not
completely walk away i would have to
pause the protocol and it waits for user
feedback to move a plate from a thermal
from a thermal unit to a magnet and then
back again but at least i don't have to
stop in the middle of a wash to reset
tip boxes
now let's look at some of the quality
control stuff
quantification normalization and pooling
so after extraction i would do the
quality control checks i would quantify
it but i would have to make a plate put
it to the plate reader wait for those
values as csv add it into
my script for the normalization so i
would know how much i would need to
normalize each step
so
if they're looking for ways to sort of
ease that transition that
transition between having to stop and
move on to the next step
and then i like to make particular
mention of all the manual pain points i
was a primary user in a clinical lab
doing the library prep by hand and for
me with plenty of experience what are
the most painful
points that i would that automation
would be able to solve
normally normalization having to treat
each sample with a single pipette
normalizing it to the
concentration i want going one by one by
one
barcode tracking having to track which
barcode was used where
in an ideal world a computer or a limb
system would take track keep track of
that but we do not live in an ideal
world
ampere purification that was a major
pain point
if you've done it before it's easy but
if you do it three times a day every day
uh it becomes quite tedious so
automation is a big help there
and qpcr when we get into it you'll see
it's very sensitive it requires very
careful pipetting and handling the
amount of samples you have you're going
to multiply it by
multiple replicates multiple dilutions
you could quick very quickly fill up a
3d four well plate having to do that
consistently from day to day uh you
could
get a lot of variability sometimes if
you don't have enough coffee at the in
the morning or maybe you had too much
coffee and your pipetting is a little
jittery
here is normalization i'll get into the
details in a minute but this is using a
single tip to treat each sample diluting
it whatever volume is necessary to bring
it to
a hundred nanograms per sample in order
to start the library prep
all the various steps that go into the
library prep whether it's fragmentation
or regular and repair
once the library prep is done you have
your prepared sample and so going
through another round of qc making
certain that you have enough dna in
order to
pool and put on the sequencer you don't
want to have excessive amounts of pcr
cycles because that could lead to pcr
duplicates it sort of degrades the
quality
sample
another round of normalization to make
all the samples
normalized and diluted down ready for
qpcr this is diluting them down to about
one nanogram per microliter
and here doing qpcr setup on deck
this is using a
p20 on a multi-channel pipetting into a
384 well plate
for the qpcr we're doing the dilutions
on the robot so if you have a
one
nanogram per microliter sample that
could approximately be
four nanomolar and so for the
pcr quantification you dilute that down
to
by a thousand to about four pico molar
and then once you have your final
samples and all qualified you have the
data back from the qpcr you know roughly
what concentration they are pulling them
all together until you have maybe one or
two tubes of your pooled libraries ready
for sequencing
once you have an established protocol
maybe even thrown on the sequencer i get
a sense of how your data looks there's a
few variables you can change here the
other steps the pico green the
normalization the qpcr won't change but
within the library prep protocol you can
tinker it around
depending on what your sample is and
maybe even what sequencer you want to
run it on you can change a few things
like fragmentation time either longer or
shorter the amount of pcr cycles maybe
you're producing too
significantly more or you're not enough
maybe you want a few more
a little bit more dna so you have some
breathing room and clean up science
selection maybe there's a few
weird lumps in the fragment traces you
want to tighten up the size selection
so i mentioned here that we were doing
normalization with a multi-channel doing
a single tip pickup
here's some data from the normalizations
this is sort of a contrived random plate
of samples the cv is about thirty
percent
using the robot trying to get the
aim trying to dilute it down to six
nanograms per microliter
you see the result is like 5.8 the cv as
low as like three percent
going from 30 cv to 3
so even if your library prep the cv is a
little bit high the normalization if you
do a normalization step you can even
that out
and on the
column it's in the middle that's
diluting it down to one nanogram per
micrometer
so if i were to do this uh
normally i would set up my robots i
would do all the library prep i would
get my quantifications i would stop i
would clean out the deck i would switch
out the multi-channels and put single
channels in there so that i could do
normalization
but i had a little work around in which
using the the very flexible python
scripting i'm able to pick up just a
single tip using a multi-channel and use
that to pipette into each well
individually and these are the results i
was getting from using a p300
this was just using a p300 you can use a
p20 but it's not as
smooth there's a few snags so this was
just using a p300 being able to
normalize
all these columns
here's that quantification slide again
so now we're going to talk a few things
about qpcr
so your samples are normalized they're
diluted down to about four nanomolar
which is one nanogram per microliter
about four nanomolar
the aluminum
modification kits usually come with
primers
for p5 p7 to amplify those regions
uh there's like a representative library
on the left you see the
the green and the yellow that's the p5
p7 regions so if your molecule has that
it will bind to the flow cell and form a
cluster
so that's what the
qpcr is
amplifying and it's usually included
with a dive that will
a double stranded die so anything that
amplifies
will fluoresce
so you don't need any necessary specific
primer
probes
the image on the right
this is to show that quantification of
your final library is very important
once you put it on the sequencer it's
akin to throwing a handful of seeds into
like a yard you don't want to be too
crowded but also you want enough
coverage so under clustering the little
circle on the left that's where not
enough landed you will get molecule
sequence but you're not using sort of
all the extra space on that flow cell
the one in the middle representing you
know that's good clustering
and the one on the right showing what
happens when you over cluster
so if your
was off or you didn't bother or there
was something wrong you could be loading
too much dna
those samples
those molecules will be binding forming
clusters but they'll begin to overlap
and the image gets so messy that the
algorithm can't pick out individual
clusters and we'll have to throw the
whole thing out
uh here are some tips for your qpcr
setup
so
mechanically doing the dilutions and
adding it to a plate largely depends on
the amount of samples and the plate size
you have if you can if you have a 96 or
384
head qpcr instrument
so what we did in the ot2 was a serial
dilution so you have four nanomolar
libraries you're diluting it down to
two people to four pico molar and
running it against a bunch of standards
usually it's from like two
pico molar down to point zero zero to
pico molar i believe yeah so six
a serial dilution of six different
concentrations
so after you have a new library made you
could run it on the qpcr and get an
estimate of where it falls
if there's like too much variability if
it's varying by like a thousand fold
something might probably went wrong
so after a while you compare it down to
the standards of maybe just like four
standards
other tips again using 20 microliter
volumes is good for
you'll need extra dead space and it's
better for
precision pipetting
you want to do technical replicas so if
you have a sample you want to run it
like three times and you want to do a
dilution replicate if you have a sample
dilute it out by 10 so you could get
like a broader coverage of how that
sample performs at two different
concentrations
the most
helpful tip that i've had was to re-run
previous libraries as controls
so if you have a library that ran
decently well on a therm on a sequencer
and you know the cluster density that
you get from it
that is something you should hang on to
and use it as a standard when you run
your next qpcr for your future libraries
this is showing not only how well your
individual sample performed but also how
well it performed on this particular
instrument so it's a handy thing to have
for your standards
you can only use them really two or
three times before especially the lower
concentrations get a bit
funky
diluting your samples down in a tween
solution
building these samples down to
about four pico molar leaves them
so dilute that they might start sticking
to the plastic labware
know your fragment size if you have a
fragment analyzer or if you could spare
enough sample to run it on a gel
you can run a milk curve afterwards is a
good way to check for dimers or any
other weird size populations
and your sample should come out at
around standard two
these are the standards from two
separate illumina quantification kits
they were diluted and pipe headed using
the ot2
and your sample should come out
around the second standard two picomolar
or one picomolar
i want to switch gears here and talk
about
different forms of normalization so i
found this recently and i thought it was
pretty cool this is a enzymatic method
of normalization
so once i got to qpcr doing all those
samples all those replicas filling up a
3d four-wheel plate thinking of other
other ways sort of
to reduce the amount of pain points
there are other forms of normalization
besides just stopping quantifying and
then balancing them by hand
there are forms such as
bead normalization but i want to avoid
using doing yet another bead wash on the
robot
so from idt they have something it's the
xgen normalized module which is an
enzymatic way to normalize samples which
is uh automation friendly
so from my understanding of the
normalized procedure
is it swaps out your usual
adapters and barcodes and uses the
normalized
primers which have a region
that is enzyme will bind to so the
second step
first you replace the
adapters now you're doing a normalized
step which
adds a set amount of enzyme that will
bind to those adapters
anything excess of that won't be bound
then you go through pooling so you're
pulling all whatever
plexity you have 12 samples eight
samples 24 samples pull them all
together
and then finally doing a reaction that
will digest away anything that hasn't
been bound by that enzyme essentially
trimming it all down to just the
molecules that were bound by that enzyme
since it was a set amount of enzyme
added to each sample now your sample is
normalized
this is sort of a rearranged setup that
i
that the normalized module sort of uses
so the key thing here is that pooling
all these samples comes before qpcr
here's some results on the left is a
batch of eight samples that was
normalized by hand and on the right is a
batch that
went straight into the
normal lace module
so
i didn't have to quantify them i just
followed the instructions of the
normalized procedure if you see at the
bottom the cv for doing it manually is
16
and then on the right using the
normalize was 11
according to their literature they can
get lower but i was pretty happy seeing
it being able to at least match what i
could do by hand
so the key thing here was this was all
pooled before the qpcr step
so here is a breakdown between those two
different uh techniques normalization by
hand and the normal lace
the one on the
uh so these are sort of a breakdown of
the protocol metrics the amount of time
saved
is about an hour
which may not be impressive but
if you see uh the text there on the left
if it was if i wasn't pulling i was
pulling after qpcr i have 24 samples if
i do two dilutions if i have three
replicates now i'm doing 144
qpcr reactions whereas for the normal
lasers everything is pooled before qpcr
i'm able to do just six reactions
to me this is a good example of a
technique that sort of can reconfigure
the amount of samples and their setup in
order to better fit an automation format
and there you go i hope you got a good
walk through of uh the ot2 and what it's
capable of of how we approach automating
the illumina kit the
hyper prep and the neb kit
i was quite happy with the data the dna
prep samples had a low cv
sequence very well
and the biggest plus for me is it
reduced a lot of hands-on time so it
automates all these time consuming and
repetitive steps best especially the
magnetic bead cleanups
automating this comprehensive ngs
workflow on the ot2 minimizes the risk
during dna library preparation while
ensuring a quality dna library prep for
sequencing
thank you for listening that's me
matthew akana thank you
uh thank you matthew
for uh
the really informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question button located on
the far left of your screen we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for once again
let's get started
our first question here
is uh really speaking to throughput
can you normalize multiple plates at the
same time on the ot2
uh
yeah
so if you saw from the deck slides it
has up to 11 uh usable deck spaces
so you can normalize if you're only
using like one tip per sample you can
normalize up to
about like five plates uh note that it
would not be simultaneously it would be
using a single channel so it would be
doing one sample after the other so
while it can fit that many plates it
will
it will take a while
next question do you need to have a
specific dna specific
uh internal standard control in order to
quantify dna with pica green
uh so just elaborating on the
fluorescent uh quantitation there
uh yes so it kind of depends on what
instrument that you will be using to
quantify for to measure the
uh fluorescence
what we usually do is that we get a pico
green kit from thermo like the uh high
sensitivity dna kit and that comes with
uh with a control standard it's like 100
nanograms per microliter and then
you just follow your suggestions if you
need to dilute it to make like a
a series of dilutions or if you just
need a high point and a low point uh
what we we've done both ways is we've
have a qubit that requires
like a high and the low standard as well
as doing it on just a generic plate
reader in which we set up whatever
dilution standards we we want to uh
to run on our plate
got it
uh can i design a protocol for a number
of samples that are not divisible by
eight
uh yeah so if you've seen from the
uh the presentation most of my batches
were doing 24 samples which is a nice
set uh three columns of eight
but if you're doing a
number of samples that are less than
eight i would stick to using single
channel pipettes if you're doing a
sample that's like 12
what i would do was just pretty much
omit the top and bottom rows so i would
have a row of six and row of six since
i'll be using multi-channels they'll
just be
treating everything simultaneously so i
would just omit those rows so i could
fit in maybe 10 samples or 12 samples
very related to kind of protocol design
we have a question here on the tip
reusing that you mentioned during the uh
presentation is tip reusing now
programmed into the gui or only python
scripting so
please elaborate
right now it is only in python scripting
uh so the gui is a good sort of
introductory use for
users new to setting up a protocol on
the ot2 but once you learn the python uh
there's a lot more flexibility so tip
reusing which i do for just the washes
is something that i was able to figure
i'm not a programmer i just started
learning a few of the python scripts so
it was something i wanted to set up and
then you could treat it separately you
can make it i want to use tips and then
put them back into like a designated tip
box
or i want to reuse tips but then just to
be safe i want to make the pipette head
move slower just in case there's any
random droplet so with like the
trade-off is no it's not on the gui but
on python there's a lot more flexibility
in how you could sort of use the tips
got it uh another question here are your
negative control pcrs adequately clean
when using the ot2 for pcr setup do you
need to have pre and post pcr robots uh
or has this been a problem in the past
uh so far for me most of my pcr on deck
is using the on-deck thermocycler and
things have been pretty clean again a
lot of it is just general ngs library
prep which is pretty robust
uh
if you work in a clinical lab you do
want to keep things sort of separate
from pre and post pcr
especially for ngs because a lot of the
universal primers are adapters uh
there's fear that if they're circulating
something could amplify
so
uh previous users would ask that
question and my suggestion is yeah you
would have to sort of to keep things
clear compliant you would break things
up to pre and post pcr like two separate
reactions
uh the other option is the
uh not listed or it might have been
listed i kind of forget is that the ot2
does have a hepa filter that could be
fitted on top
the box itself
of the ot-2 is not airtight there is
circulation but you could put a hepa
filter on top to keep things uh cleaner
on the inside if you worry about
anything circulating
very helpful
uh so another question here
uh
pretty specific uh what should be the
minimum concentration of bacterial
genomic dna for whole genome sequencing
matthew i'll leave the witness here i'm
hoping you can speak to kind of
different ranges of dna templates that
you've used in your experience with the
ot2 library prep
um
speaking on that most of my samples have
been 100 to like 50 nanograms of like
just extracted dna
um
there's like a broad range i would
assume of different applications
different things you're going to be
investigating so if you have a
particular sort of uh protocol in mind i
would look into like their user
suggestions a lot of them do have sort
of like a low input
uh
protocol that would sort of
either introduce extra pcr or if you're
concerned about like pcr errors it would
do like pcr free
so it treats the protocol a little bit
differently depending on how much input
like if you could spare extra you could
use a standard input but if you're
concerned about like a very low amount
they have particular protocols all them
you know it's just changing a few steps
on the on the existing ot2 protocols but
they have stuff in particular if you
have like a very low input
i would say i think the general cutoff
i've seen is like around below 10
nanograms of dna
you would use like a low input protocol
absolutely
what is the python code to pick up a
single tip using a multi-channel pipette
head very
specific to the python api here but
how have you accomplished this uh in
library prep
protocols
um there's two different ways one
i've done i sort of again i'm uh
i'm mostly new to python but i was able
to sort of jury rig a tip pickup by just
saying a bit of
physical offsets so you have to make
certain the deck is clear but a better
suggestion i believe there's a like a
technical note we have it
from the app's engineering team about
how to sort of do a single tip pickup um
the
requirement is you have to be a little
bit familiar with the python protocol
and sort of how to make a few changes
but there's like some
variables within the tip pickup factor
to sort of make it a more
gentle pickup so you don't crush
anything
so i believe we can share that
yeah definitely refer to our support
documentation on opentrons.com
for for more detailed uh reference to
the code there
uh
a question about dead volume how do you
overcome some of the dead volume with
the these very sensitive library prep
workflows
um
the way i've done it is if i can get
away with everything being pre-aliquoted
into like a strip tube
uh
i would do it that way i've when i do it
that way i check
sometimes they sell
the protocol kits in like 24 samples so
i would measure how much do they provide
so therefore how much extra dead space
do they allow
um some
are more finicky and so what i would do
is i would put like a foil seal on top
of the well so there's no evaporation
uh over the course of the protocols when
it goes to that reagent it should still
be uh
there
some of the foil seals i'm trying to
look for one but
most of the foils the foil seals that
i've used are like puncturable so i
could put a foil seal on there not worry
too much about anything
the pipette would go in there poke a
hole actually like
poke a hole
widen the hole just a bit and then take
the reagent out
thank you
uh we have a question here about a low
yielding
library prep that someone is optimizing
even manually potentially so
is there anything that you can
speak to specifically about
troubleshooting a low yielding kind of
library prep workflow
oh there's
a lot of steps the ones that i think are
the biggest culprit if you have a
protocol and it works fine manually
versus putting on the robot so it could
come down to the the way the robot hand
handles it
the main culprits that i've seen from my
experience are either the ampere cleanup
with the magbeads
or uh some of the reagent pipetting for
the ampere the usual thing is either the
beat settling time either you have like
a large volume and it takes forever for
the beast to settle and so when you move
the supernate you usually can get like
beat carry over when in into the waist
so you lose you're losing dna
that or not
removing all the ethanol maybe the tips
are misaligned you're not getting all
the way to the bottom so there's still
ethanol in there when you do the
resuspension
uh the other culprit could be sort of
the re
the reagent mixing
of all the
sort of reagent enzymatic steps usually
it's
ligation the ligase or sometimes the
fragmentation
those buffers could be extra thick or
viscous and so
compared to do it just manually yeah you
could do a lot of physical pipetting and
mixing but with the robot you would
probably want to increase
the pipette mixing step
so that the ligase buffer is like fully
mixed in with the reagent sample
yeah a bit of a root cause analysis
there
while you're mentioning kind of
pipetting efficiency are there any
recommendations for quick and effective
pipette mixing especially on full plates
of libraries prepared
from my presentation i'm sort of
mentioning that yeah you might have
diminishing returns if you want to do
32 samples 40 samples because the pipet
the multi-channel pipette head is going
to have to go in and
physically mix each column one by one
uh
there are options if you want to push it
to like a 48 samples or even 96 samples
instead of using the multi-channel
mixing it one by one would be just to
stop the protocol and move it onto a
separate shaker so it could shake the
entire thing at once and then maybe do a
spin if you need if you're worried about
it being shaken too much i do believe we
have a heater shaker coming for the ot2
so that will be an on deck
uh shaker
that you can do all your reagent
addition let's say you're doing an
ampere you add the ampere beads and it
will shake the entire 96 plate at once
so you don't have to go and manually mix
each thing one by one because if you're
doing things one by one maybe one column
has to sit a lot longer while all the
other columns get washed so you might
get some unevenness whereas the heater
shaker will shake the entire thing
uh we've got some more questions coming
in uh related to
uh bead cleanup on the ot2 as you're
referring to the ampere
cleanup have you noticed any over drying
of beads before the samples are able to
be resuspended great question here
um
i personally haven't i have
noticed uh under drying
uh just switching protocols and plates
sometimes it would under dry compared to
overdrive
overdrive that happens yeah you would
just reduce the uh
your pauses or the weights it has for
evaporation
what it
turned out to be for a previous case
was that
sometimes the samples were in a
a 200 microliter plate versus a one mil
deep well plate so the one mole depot
plate had a lot less air circulation so
it didn't evaporate as fast as the
shorter plate
so for that even though the timing steps
were the same and the volumes are the
same there was a lot more of the ethanol
that didn't get evaporated away
and if you do have cases
or if you're worried about
over drying would be increasing sort of
the resuspension steps the ones that i
have
physically locate the tip against the
surface of the bead the bead pellet so
that the
washing is a little bit more vigorous
than just pipetting into like the center
of the well
[Music]
very helpful
um
one question are there plans for
or are there already webinars for more
in-depth informational sessions on the
python protocol development
i'll take this one matthew if there are
python questions please check it out
please check out the webinar section of
our website opentrons.com
there are previous webinars to reference
on the python api with our uh really
talented applications engineering team
leading that
so please check those out there will
definitely be more in the future because
there's there's quite a bit of interest
in that as i can tell from the questions
we're getting today
i have one more question for you
matthew here as we're coming at that
time
can the ot 2 perform any other ngs steps
such as extraction
uh yeah so if you remember
my presentation slide of all the steps
one after the other extraction is the
very first one
i've able to incorporate a version that
works uh for me with a setup that i like
um
all the extractions are basic sort of
bead
bead
extraction kits
the
one condition is that uh it does require
a bit more of the deck setup because
the amount of sample in the beads and
mount washes leads to a lot more liquid
liquid waste so you have to account for
i don't want to just dump the liquid
into like the trash receptacle so i have
like deep well plates just for all
liquid waste
i just had like one more notice uh
thank you for going through all the
protocol
my big suggestion is to sort of follow
your once you have a kid or protocol in
mind is to follow their recommendations
so the slides like the workflow i
presented was sort of like a generic
basic template for a lot of people to
get started but sometimes the
manufacturer might require
something
is like more optimized for sonication
instead of the
fragmentation by enzymatic means or
sometimes
based on your results everything every
lab is different maybe you need like
tighter
uh fragmentation sizes so you can
include like the ampere bead size
selection so that would be like a whole
step unto itself because it uses so many
tips and that could come like early on
it could come like later in the protocol
it could come like after the library
prep
so
one of the benefits of all these
protocols and stuff that i've
experienced is very flexible i'm able to
sort of
slot around different steps include
or
skip over certain steps within my
protocols in order to get the like the
sample sizes or specificity that i want
uh thank you matthew for speaking to the
the flexibility of the platform
uh before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand lab roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye
you